eric tricot bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin on le
disait une quatrième vague redouté et il
y a aussi une crainte d'un manque de
personnel à l'hôpital notamment liée à
la démission de soignants quelle est
l'ampleur du phénomène
elle est il ya différents niveaux iv e
dramatique
il est dramatique parce que les
personnels qui font qu'on laisse les
places vides sûrement landrush était le
maintien en tant que personnel une fois
les hôpitaux à une embauche des
personnels qui paraît peut-être sous
qualifiés en tout cas souhaité expertise
et/ou tout d'experts dans l'extraction
comprenez parce que tout simplement pour
charges de personnel expert dans la
prise en charge de différentes
pathologies
il faut des années d'expérience je vais
les dédoublements dans la tête parce que
les personnels qu entité aussi les
hôpitaux qui ont été contraints d avg
humilié a battu par une politique
institutionnelle il est d'animer le plus
bas que les thèmes je rappelle qu'ils
encore un an et même de soignants
étaient des héros ont été accueillis
tous les gens à 20h02 des rohan dépassé
à vecteur de la maladie
pourquoi on perd et que tel n'était pas
bien notre travail des soignants et non
pas les règles date est fier d'eux et
d'un commando d'hygiène et qui
maintenant nous sommes 30 à une autre à
une autre problématique qui est lié aux
10 à un débat et elle bâtit nation
obligatoire pour les personnels fournis
non pour rester connecté en temps café
avec gagnante est quand même très
compliqué à gérer et je veux comprendre
et 40 % qu'à peu près les chiffres entre
les 40% des personnels fémur
actuellement qui vont des lidl ou qui
tout va des bois et paradoxalement dans
ce nombre de gens qui vont partir
professionnels ont été l'institution
ils n'y vont pas pour suivre leur métier
de datchas mais beaucoup moins tenir les
leurs y méprendre à une reconversion
professionnelle de la démocratie dans
des spas y travailler
ailleurs vraiment il ya eu un esprit de
confiance des personnels la motivation
qui avait une prévenir veillant à
s'occuper des patients et là on les a
littéralement ont calé mais c'est une
politique qualité requis en place depuis
30 ans effectivement après la première
vague ils avaient eux aussi des
démissions on se souvient mais depuis
rien n'a changé finalement puisque nous
comme que d'endettement de délégations
d'autres gouvernements qui ont parlé
viennent pas évident et sont des livres
et ils sont capables d'annoncer que ils
vont réduire les dégâts ponelle en sept
points
quelle est la même que pour cher à
l'aide soignant il faut un an
thaddée juste une partie des quotas il
faut bien dans des cols produits en les
soignant il faut trois ans profil
infirmer aucun achat mais il était dit
que je vais je suis c'est trois ans la
fia mais depuis ce 202e les garçons
travaillent tous deux ans d'école savez
en tout cette année pour être jamais
allé et j'ai deux temps juste comme ça
que je déconne je ne parle pas un fred l
expertise pour n'avoir et pourra
acquérir en étant sur le travail donc
voyez étaient en excursion du plan
communication on l'a en plus que java
délire pour des m'a dit avec un permis
de pratique et rentes ai alors dit fond
il faut de métier d'infirmier vous le
mettez médecins il est très évolutif
puisque la médecine et évolutive ou et
il faut pas faire un apport total faut
pas mettre la charrue avant les boeufs
et l'a littéralement est ce que faire
ces gouvernements humains pouvant
recruter recruter du personnel
mais il est dans laquelle s'est
platement n'y a pas de sortie d'école
alors la seule façon que l'on a mis
avant d'être attractif il enfile des
lives et les partenaires les papilles
l'elysée l'état reconnaît il faut avoir
des salaires compter quand je rappelle
qu'il ya encore quelques années et
quelques moins de personnels des
hôpitaux d'état que des urgences mais
aussi les blocs opératoires
j'en ai des opérations elle contient des
dalles de tv étaient en grève il faut
ainsi fidéliser les partenaires commande
un en-avant des pleins gens vivent bien
avoir un côté social de traction tcs
approché le gouvernement au film c'est à
dire embaucher des temps travaillé dans
des crèches qui permet au personnel
d'avoir des places degré et d'avoir opté
possibilité d'être augmenté lentement et
oni bien sûr avoir un pouvoir d'achat
qu'une fois supérieur achemine
actuellement au classement moyen de
l'aider mais qui malheureusement oblige
les soignants à s'expatrier pour habiter
de plus en plus loin de la région
parisienne avec des temps de travail qui
augmente et nous par exemple tient du 15
au 30 mai on a la possibilité parce que
l'on travaille de concert avec la
direction générale de la tht pour avoir
des semaines sur quelques jours un peu
communication en espagne un peu comme on
lui demande alors que j'étais son nouvel
et quelqu'un qui m'écoutent pareil avec
par exemple une nouvelle case horaire de
8 8 c'est bien j'en ai eu tous
complètement a contrario de l'antenne
localisation du pont travail qui avaient
été validées tamani qu'un qui était la
tête d'eads et non objective des
semaines de travail à quatre jours des
soldes en 15 jours 3 jours de travail
3 jean temps de repos supplémentaire par
semaine qui permet peut être qu'on ne
débatte mais nous avec du temps avec et
lentement et avec la famille et de honte
d'avoir un petit peu de repos et de quoi
récupérer le papier encore quoique 2011
comme dans une non n'est pas continent
par deux véhicules de vide et on est
bien une people et cuisez pas me rater
merci à vous et eric tricot pour votre
témoignage je le rappelle vous êtes
infirmier anesthésiste à l'hôpital chu
mondor et membre de sud santé